shaw was just about to
sound off on shikari richardson man
you know what i mean what what's the
deal what do you think what do you think
the issue is there what's going on huh
listen she she's uh she's a very
attractive lady i'm actually a fan but i
thought it was weird like did you see
the nipple piercings no really what oh
she's a freak
you're thinking of cuomo sorry
my bad yeah yeah but um with her right
so she makes this big fuss about smoking
weed right yeah whether it's enhanced
performance enhanced or not you're the
one that did it you know the rules yeah
so you gotta you gotta live with what
they gave to you yeah and then she was
like damn and everyone's like this such
a shame she should be in a race and the
whole time like i know a little about
tracking like well she wouldn't even
finish the top five so you knew that
going into it i figured everybody did i
was gassed up i thought she was the
fastest woman on the planet i even said
it on the podcast i was like i said it
on the podcast i was like the fastest
woman got hustled son i had mad
jamaicans in the dm's like what the [ __ ]
you talking about what are you talking
about
yeah the jamaicans were like
what yeah yeah and then you know they
did this whatever fontaine classic yeah
she got lit smoked and still talk [ __ ]
yeah she was like i'm the sixth fastest
woman ever should i beats by dre and
even dre was like damn man how did you
not look into this yeah
yeah it's weird because like
running is one of those sports where i
don't think you could have a bad day
like that
no you're fast you're fast yeah it's
just like you're running yeah you know i
understand like basketball like maybe
there's something off with your shot but
like running is just running like that's
the one thing you can control straight
line exactly
right it's like if you're injured you
can't run but if you're not injured you
don't run a second slower and then also
everyone's like right mark why are you
looking at me like i'm saying something
people people said people say that
ronnie's more technical than that and
why because
you just run she's running a straight
line yeah well you got to come off the
block with power you got to have your
timing right you got to have your stride
right let's keep that keep talking keep
talking
i read it on reddit okay they said
that's how you got it that's how you
went no no no no no no no what keep i
want you to keep explaining running and
because as you explain you're going to
lose confidence in your no no no yeah
yeah yeah no it's just putting around
every olympic sport is is extremely
technical not every olympics
running is extremely tight it's not
technical at all it's just running
you're either fast or not fast how much
do you think usain bolt really trained
a lot
you're seeing around the 40 when he was
at the combine they're like hey were you
running he's like i really don't want
him i'm like seven beers deep like just
run a 40. he's in sweats and [ __ ] he's
like all right let me try it out ran
like a three nine there you go wow demon
warm up like it was like all right
that's what years of technique and
training will do i guess
yeah that's what it is technique and
training okay so shikari comes in ninth
and what i was pissed off about is she
like dropped out of the 200. did you
guys see that
after this this yeah yeah that's some
soft [ __ ] just say you're injured
fake an injury like remember michael
johnson you remember the michael johnson
the runner yeah yeah yeah the gold
cleats long neck what was it lockhart
long neck why are you calling him a
really long neck michael johnson yeah
you had a long neck look him up short no
yeah long neck dog it's pretty good we
got video yeah hell yeah we got video
hold on we got to look good for his long
neck i don't know if he was like
that's that white kid who's like a meme
there's also that guy there's that guy
but he was in fast
okay let's see this guy's get a neck on
him all running
i don't think he had a long neck at all
he had a very short neck yeah no look at
his neck there look at another go go up
yeah look at his neck right there that's
not a long neck for you that's a long
night i'm pushing it i'm reaching
are you going down the one to the longer
you tell me that's it yo i'll say i'll
say it's long if you say running
technical okay if you bail me out i'll
bail you out all right let's go dude
that's a long ass imagine that like some
tribal woman with the rings around her
[ __ ]
but not this this is a regular heads hey
i want to remember
michael jackson no no this did you just
made something up right now yeah you
said i used to call him long there's no
way i've never referred to him
anyway that dude i think he was like he
raised some guy in the hundred fifty
it was like who's gonna be the fastest
person on the planet and once he found
out that the guy was smoking him he just
pulled up with like a hammy yeah
i don't know but shikari i think that uh
i think she'll she'll uh she'll be back
she'll be fine she'll be back she'll be
fine she'll be driving over to win gold
but yeah yeah yeah yeah do you think
she'll actually keep competing i was
joking i think that it's a wrap for her
but actually yeah i think she might be
the highest paid like track star of the
last like five years not now not now
that's why that road sailed you think so
wait why why she's still got the nike
contracts like she's like all that [ __ ]
goes away because now they're like oh
damn she's six fastest
ninth no like
given nine nights
i think they know one like with this one
race they didn't though they didn't
though what do you mean i i think they
assumed that she was gonna oh she missed
she's she's why did she's gonna get us
gold yeah now there's all this pressure
on her i think yeah i'm with you i think
she's [ __ ] i don't know
i think she can do i think the weed show
is the best thing that ever happened to
her why because now she's on the map
like if she went to tokyo and got second
third didn't place like it just would be
a non-story like there's an american kid
that got second in the men's hundred
meter i don't know who he is i don't
know his name i don't know i know
nothing about it because i didn't know
who she was until yeah me neither she
got crazy press and now she's like in
the ether like she's in the ecosystem
exactly and now she's doing conor
mcgregor type antics like [ __ ] talking
after the thing like but you should talk
about it but the same thing with that
you gotta win but you gotta win fair
you